For this video, I’m going to show you how
to take a few simple ingredients, and make
mountains and mountains of your own custom
gummy candies, at home.
Start with a box of Jell-O, some corn syrup,
and a few packets of unflavored gelatin. The
small boxes like this have 4 packets inside,
and for this recipe, you’ll actually only
need 2 of them.
Get started by measuring out 1/2 cup of very
cold water, then squirt in 1/4 cup of corn
syrup. Cold water will help the gelatin separate
properly, and the corn syrup is going to give
our gummies a nice smooth texture.
Now we need the corn syrup fully dissolved,
so give it a good stirring until the water
turns completely clear. Then go ahead and
pour the sugary liquid into a pot. But don’t
turn on the stove just yet. I’ll show you
what happens if you do in just a minute.
Go ahead and add both packets of unflavored
gelatin to the pot, then pour in the entire
packet of Jell-O.
Now it’s going to take a minute or two for
the gelatin to absorb into the water, but
take your time and be patient so you don’t
make a mess. And keep stirring it slowly,
until you can see all the gelatin is mixed
in.
Alright, it’s time to heat things up, and
turn this sugary soup, into a delicious candy syrup.
Set your stove to medium-low heat, for around
5-10 minutes, making sure to stir the candy
mix every minute or two, to keep it from burning.
While that’s warming, it’s a good idea
to find something you can use as a candy mold,
like these ice cube trays, I found at the
LEGO store.
When you see the gelatin has completely liquified,
the syrup is ready for pouring. And you should
be able to pour it straight into the molds.
But be careful not to spill, because the syrup’s
extremely hot, and will burn you.
Now if you see little lumps, clumps or bubbles
floating to the top, it’s probably because
you didn’t start with cold water, or you
heated up the mixture too fast for the gelatin to fully separate.
But don’t worry. There’s a really easy
way to fix it.
Pour all of the syrup into a tall and narrow,
heat-resistant container, like a large drinking
glass. As you do, you’ll immediately notice
all the bubbles and gelatin lumps, start rising
to the top. Let it sit for around 10 minutes
to give it all a good chance to settle and
cool a bit, and you’ll soon see all the
impurities collect together at the top, and
separate into a layer of gummy foam.
Now check this out. All you have to do is
reach in with a spoon or a spatula and scrape
this newly formed skin away. Just like that,
you’ve got yourself a beautiful, and impressively
clean gummy syrup, ready for casting. And
to make the next steps as easy as possible,
I’m collecting the magical syrup, in a condiment
container.
These kinds of containers are perfect for
filling up your molds. They’re super easy
to control, and you can squirt the syrup exactly
where you need it, which helps avoid spilling,
or overflowing the molds with too much gummy.
I gave these candies a few hours to cool,
so you can see just how much of a difference
it makes, to take the extra step and skim
the bubbles off the top, before making your candies.
Alright, let’s see how our gummy mix does
with a much more intricate, and detailed ice
cube mold, like this one. And you might have
noticed that this time, the syrup, is impressively clear.
5 hours later, we’ve got ourselves a batch
of really cool, LEGO gummy guys. Which apparently,
are balanced enough, that they can stand up
on their own. That’s kind of cool.
Now just for fun, I made a silicone mold from
actual LEGO bricks, and a 2 part silicone
mix from a special effects supply store..
Now you should know that when the syrup cools
down, it’s going to shrink a little. So
to compensate for that, try filling the molds
just a tiny bit higher than the top.
For one finishing touch, I got a clean LEGO
baseplate, and brushed it lightly with vegetable
oil, then carefully placed it down on top
of the mold. You can see the edges have little
dimples, to help keep all the studs perfectly
aligned. So all it needs now is something
like a heavy book to give it some weight,
and hold it in place.
I let these ones cool on the counter for around
6 hours, and you can see that if we carefully
remove the baseplate now, our little LEGO
gummies, have small divots on the bottom,
which means they’re connectable.
Let’s take one of the bricks out out of
the mold, and take a good look up close. You
can see there’s a surprising amount of detail
captured in the gummy snack, and they’re
not sticky at all, but actually quite firm,
and they smell delicious.
You probably also noticed they’re completely
transparent, which puts their level of awesomeness
on a completely different scale.
Alright let’s take this idea to the next
level with different colors and different flavors.
I tripled the recipes and made 7 different
batches. Then let them cool overnight so they’d
all be crystal clear. Now if you try doing
this yourself, you might find that getting
them out of the cups is pretty tricky.
When you do get them out though, you’ll
have a gob of gummy, that way too big to eat
on it’s own. But that’s ok because what
we’re really after here is the white layer
of gummy foam at the top.
Now if you’re really careful, you can use
something like a kitchen knife to slowly trim
the top layer off, which will leave you with
a huge chunk of gummy goodness. And these
transparent gummy blocks can be re-melted
on medium-low heat, and molded into any shape you want.
I made a candy mountain, of LEGO gummy bricks,
in all kinds of colors, shapes and sizes.
And if you look closely, you can even see
some little gummy guys in there as well.
In keeping with the LEGO theme, I went back
to the store and picked up a bunch of containers,
just so I could have a unique place, to store
my custom candies.
Now you could keep all your LEGO gummies separate,
but I ended up mixing all mine together and
filling the containers with all kinds of random
pieces. How awesome is that?
The best part is, if you snap on the lid and
keep them in the fridge, they can stay good
for up to a month.
Now since the gummies are interlocking, you
might be wondering if you can build things
with them as well. The answer is yes, as long
as you can resist the temptation to snack
on them first.
For one last experiment, try finding a handful
of chewable vitamin C tablets, and powderize
them in a blender for about 30 seconds. I
used 8 tablets, or 4,000 mg for this batch,
and when you mix the powder into the gummy
syrup, you’ve just made your candies, vitamin
C enriched. Of course these are a slightly
healthier version, but more importantly, it
gives them a slightly sour taste, making them
even more delicious, and extremely addictive.
Well now you know how to use a few simple
ingredients to make a bucketful, of colorful
LEGO gummies. That are stackable, snack-able,
and fun to share.
By the way, you don’t have to make your
gummies into LEGOs. You can actually make
any thing you can think of. I converted some
of my left over syrup, into an assortment
of AA, AAA, and D cell batteries.
Well that’s it for now. If you like this
project, perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com